time for turn the page tuesday we start
with a lot of the positives there with
your top five ride now we get to the
teams who need to flip that page the
chicago bears the pages have been
turning a little bit after what i would
call an extremely
slow start now justin fields becomes the
quarterback
what do they look like since
well they definitely need to turn the
page and they're two-and-oh since that
cleveland debacle when he got sacked a
bunch of times and and now they have the
packers on the horizon i know they're
celebrating the win but at the end of
the day you got to turn that page and
start focusing on the packers and
focusing on how you're going to score
points from the offensive side of
the ball defensively yeah you've been
riding your defense but at the end of
the day you're not gonna compete with
aaron rodgers and that green bay offense
unless they can score some points
offensively and secondly they have to
protect justin fields i know he's young
and he's strong but those hits they
continue to add up over the season and
eventually wear you down he has to play
smarter too get his butt down and don't
take those big hits
yeah he's taking a bunch and i'm with
you if you're gonna if you're gonna
compete there in the north there's no
way that you're gonna be able to do it
unless you just start trusting in fields
and like if you go watch him at ohio
state he's capable of dropping back and
passing 25 30 times a game he's capable
of running and orchestrating that type
of offense and i think you need to
slowly start to put that on his plate
maybe not all at once but they've been
super super conservative with them so
far and been able to do it been able to
beat some bad teams with that strategy
but i just think you need to start
really trusting him because this offense
is ultimately going to go as far as
fields takes it and i think he can
handle a bit more than they've been
giving him giving him so far give him a
few more opportunities to push the ball
down the field but like you're saying
that protection has been a serious issue
the one game basically couldn't even get
a ball off where they had negative one
yards total offense
yeah i don't have anything else
[Laughter]
okay perfect let's get to our second
team the cincinnati bengals they
couldn't hit a kick here in cincinnati
that there's so much belief right now
with joe burrow in the direction this
team is going and they had so many
opportunities our guy mason crosby kept
missing him late the bengals have a
chance another chance another chance
despite all the borough interceptions
what's the story of the bengal season so
far i i just think the bingo's are
giving a terrific effort every single
week that's the thing that i see the
bingos can and this this past loss
should prove to them that they can play
with anybody in the national football
league you don't think about um joe
mixon higgins
all those guys are really impressive but
at the end of the day man you got to
have confidence that you can play with
anybody and this team is loaded with
talent they're starting to trust each
other they're starting to come together
and aside from some some uh some missed
kicks field goals man these guys could
like you said
he they could have won this game and
they should understand that they can
compete with anybody in national
football league
well i think they should be feeling that
right now i mean they go into pittsburgh
beat the steelers handily then they come
back home and they go toe-to-toe with
aaron rodgers and they should have
beaten them i think a big story with
green bay is jair alexander and his
injury his shoulder that he's going to
miss a ton of time with now
what that means for the packers over the
long term how does green bay without
their best corner and now with basically
a rookie and a backup quarter and kevin
king how do they put the pieces back
together because jamar chase exposed
them that's a rookie wide receiver who
had a bad preseason who's had an awesome
preseason who was just exposing their
secondary that trend will continue
without alexander so i am worried about
where this team goes long term but for
the bengals i think the pieces are all
there and is it all going to be perfect
this year maybe not i think this is a
potential playoff team this year is
going to have to battle a really tough
second half of their schedule but as i
look to next year and maybe a year after
that
this is a team that can compete for
championships i think they're built with
a ton of talent and i'm believing in joe
burrow overall i just think he has a
different kind of mind about him and
that continues to show its face on the
field as he goes head to head with aaron
rodgers and should have won
yeah i like you know i like the defense
i like bates and von bell and those guys
and you just see on the defensive side
of the ball those guys are flying around
they're playing with enthusiasm and they
believe that hey we're not the old
bengals we're not the same old bengals
we got some new blood in here we finally
have a head we got a um a quarterback we
got a running back we got weapons on the
outside we got a defense that plays
extremely hard so if if i'm with the
bengals i'm pretty confident just like
you if they don't make the playoffs this
year i see this team making the playoffs
next year and in into the future they're
going to be a problem to be dealt with
the next 10 years because joe burrow is
going to continue to get better and
trust me he doesn't want to continue to
turn the ball on that's turn the ball
over that's something that he's going to
continue to work on
it's it's crazy to think like big ben is
probably really not even probably he is
the least talented quarterback in the
afc north right the least talented baker
mayfield lamar jackson joe burrow i'm
taking any of those three with ease over
big ben roethlisberger get you to your
final one
in vegas it will now be the special
teams coordinator who's going to take
over as the head coach so what about
this raiders offense
carr he's been some added responsibility
but really it is it is gruden's offense
gruden is the play caller where does
this team go offensively whose offense
will it be who's going to call plays and
how much added responsibility now goes
to derek why are you asking me
i don't know
what are you asking me like
whoever the office coordinator is he's
gonna have to call plays but the bottom
line is this run the football you went
out and got josh jacobs for a reason and
if he can stay healthy you can run the
football you got a big offensive line
and get darren waller the ball there's
no way no
way he should go through a game without
ten to ten opportunities ten targets per
game it's just like mark andrews get him
ten targets a game he's six five six six
he's super athletic and you name me one
one linebacker one safety that can cover
this guy nobody can cover them so
if if if i'm running the offense i'm
focusing on running the ball getting the
ball to darren waller using play-action
pass and stretching the field
if you had to guess at this point and
you weren't a huge believer in the
overall oak you know not oakland vegas
raiders to begin with you really weren't
you were just saying let me wait and see
i want to get past the first month or
two of the season i want to see where
this season goes before i tell you that
i'm all the way bought in
if you had to guess at this point it's
really nothing more than a guest it's a
talented team you have no clue what the
coaching staff is going to look like
moving forward do you believe that this
season falls apart or they figure out a
way to still continue to win games
i think they're going to be average i
think they're going to be average i mean
if i look at the raiders and i had to
i had to forecast the future i would say
this is kind of a 8-9 type team maybe 7
and 10 at the worst case scenario and
that's why i told you earlier we'll have
to figure out or see exactly how their
leaders handle and how well they play
and things like that a lot of times this
could bring you together a situation
like this can bring you together and
really propel you to the next level if
you have the right leadership or
sometimes hey maybe we lose our
offensive coordinator if you're derek
carr and john gruden and maybe that
takes pressure off of him because you
know john gruden was constantly in his
face maybe this frees up derek carr i
don't know we will see what happens but
we'll see that's all i can say now
it's a it's a major wait-and-see
situation and that you just have no clue
what's gonna happen because not only was
he the coach in the play caller and
somebody who was brought in to take you
know in theory that was going to take
car to another level he like bill
belichick had complete control over the
roster mike mayok is the general manager
but mike maya couldn't make a personnel
decision without a sign off from gruden
so now it's like does mayok now take
over all of that responsibility and he
can handle trades and he can handle
personnel and is he going to choose who
the play caller is i just think there's
a billion and one unanswered questions
when it comes to the actual team moving
forward where they go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports